abigail is in springfield missouri
hi abigail what's up hi dave
um not too much how about you better
than i deserve how can we help you
uh yes sir um well me and my husband are
just
starting out with your program we're
baby pre baby step one we're getting
everything sorted out
i was just wondering what kind of advice
you would have for
someone starting out and what you would
recommend and everything
yeah well good congratulations we're
honored to have you in the tribe here
um i think what ends up happening is is
you
the first step the first thing you end
up doing is you try to figure out where
you actually
are and that's stuff like making a list
of your debts
and starting to write out your first
budget where you're actually going to
tell your money what to do and make it
behave
um and you know and then we're going to
give you a clear path
that we call the baby steps to walk
through
and you may have heard of that already
i think i've been doing a decent amount
of research the last two days
i'm curious i'm curious what led to you
finding dave and the baby steps abigail
kind of how did you get to this point
um i actually saw someone post um on
one of the facebook's pages that i was
at her name's julie goheen
and she was sharing her journey and how
they became debt free
and was talking to her and she offered
to send me the starter book
and everything and been watching your
youtube channel for the last day okay
and everything just getting more and
more excited about it
that's cool i'm honored yeah that's fun
to see someone else do it you know you
see someone else on the other side of
being debt-free you're like oh
could i do that you know that's awesome
yeah yeah maybe maybe i could have that
happen to me and i think you can abigail
so
well again welcome aboard so you're
gonna sit down do your written game plan
your written budget and you've already
seen that stuff on youtube
and lay out your debt snowball and begin
to attack your debts
it's imperative that you and your
husband work together
all of our data christie shows that
couples who work together
on almost any part of their life right
yes
they're more effective at that part
money parenting
careers building a business or whatever
i mean
if uh if they're if you guys are working
together it just makes all the
difference in the world and yeah that
means one of you is not a spectator
yeah yeah and it's interesting too
because i feel like that whenever you
are
having these conversations you'll
typically have one one of the things
that abigail said she said i'm getting
excited i was like oh good because the
excitement motivation goes a long way
yeah like
you gotta i always hear you say this
dave you say you gotta get fired up you
gotta get mad sick and tired of being
sick and tired you can wander into debt
you cannot wander out
so emotion does play a piece of this you
can't be just indifferent
and get out of debt like you've got to
actually care because change is hard but
it's interesting in marriage
i think a lot of times what we see is
there's one person that's excited and on
board and one person that is
less so less excited and so i think
what's cool is if you start having these
conversations on the front end abigail
where you and your spouse are talking
about okay what are our goals what what
are our dreams what would it look like
for us to be debt-free what could we do
if we didn't have payments
and then you both start out excited
together you both start out not only
communicating on the budget but also
with the enthusiasm that you both need
to bring to the table to actually make
the change
yeah cause you're gonna you're gonna
bust into some stuff that's gonna be
hard yes
you're gonna have to make some choices
differently right than you've ever made
in and you know we always say you have
to live like no one else so that later
you can live and give like no one else
it works
but it's hard yeah this process that we
teach is extremely effective
has a very high probability of you
succeeding
but only to the extent that you bust
into it yeah
it is easy to understand what we teach
you to do
it is hard to change your life right and
it's interesting
it's interesting too because we always
say like of all the people the millions
of people that have become debt-free you
know using our program
it's amazing how none of them are going
man i really miss those payments
i really miss being in debt they never
look back with regret and so if you
could see what it will feel like on the
other side
it will give you that motivation and
enthusiasm to push through the hard
stuff initially because
it is so worth it when you get there
yeah very good very good
well you keep listening miss abigail and
we're here to help you call anytime if
we can help you on this journey